i think it's a rise of smart government  governments doing what they do but doing  it better  and managing that through the use of big  data the enormous amounts of data that  are available now both to government and  the private sector  managing it through transparency  by revealing more performance data about  how they perform  rather like the government of india has  been doing in the last couple of years  india has seen a dramatic change in the  way in which government operates and the  change was really simple  it used to be that you had to prove as a  citizen why the government should tell  you something about its activities  now the government has to find a reason  why it shouldn't tell you something  about its activities and this has really  transformed the accountability of  government in india it's made much more  information about government activities  available  and it's revolutionized at the nature of  indian citizens engagement with their  government